hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
going to be a Suicide Squad video all
about the tattooed man who it seems like
is in this trailer it was all but
confirmed they haven't officially
confirmed it we don't see his face we
just see an example of his powers I'm
also going to talk about Scott Eastwood
a lot of people think that he might be
agent 37 aka Dick Grayson so there's
this sequence during the trailer you you
see it start right around here where a
lot of people were like WTF who is this
we can't see his face it just his powers
look super crazy
these look like crystals coming off of
them it seems like this is going to be
the tattooed man in what they've done
because this is the movie they poured
tons of money individual effects they
just cranked his powers like the way
they look on screen up to 11 one of the
many benefits of having a shitload of
money to spend on a movie you can make
it look awesome connecting a few dots
from behind the scenes pictures we see
common as tattooed man that's probably
who this is he has the ability to create
holographic projections based on tattoos
that he has on his body now it's a lot
like Green Lantern's powers which is
funny because he also showed up for the
first time in Green Lantern's comic he
was a Hal Jordan villain now there been
three different versions of the
character it seems like common the one
in this movie is the third version like
the most recent one who was part of
Deathstroke's
Titans in the comics real quick
character history so the first version
of the character's name was Abel Teran
he was a sailor that got in this
accident with chemicals and it sounds
very familiar very common origin story
he found that as a result of the
accident he was able to use the
chemicals to create mental projections
that actually had physical form so he
used the chemicals to tattoo himself so
that he could just walk around and
create holographic projections so you
see why they put him in Hal Jordans
comic they wanted a villain to go up
against Green Lantern that had similar
powers to Green Lantern the second
version of the character was named John
Oakes later in the comics he was an
inmate in a prison met the first
tattooed man the first tattooed man gave
him his powers then the new tattooed man
John Oakes went on to commit crimes as
you'd expect the third tattooed man
didn't have anything to do with the
second tattooed man he was a Marine that
went missing on an operation got
captured by a special tribe who killed
all of his comrades and tattoo their
bodies they captured him
eventually he turned and became part of
their tribe and they taught him how to
create tattoos that he could turn into
real projections they called it the art
of sin grafting essentially what the
tattooed man would do is he would graft
the sins of the people that he killed
onto his body so obviously he's a very
terrible person is he still a villain
but the more people he kills the more
tattoos he has on his body the more
powerful he becomes now this is Suicide
Squad so it's all about bad people doing
good things there was art during
Deathstroke's Titans where tattooed man
helped to destroy a device the death
stroke was trying to misuse so he did a
couple that thing's still pretty
terrible person so he could either be
working with the suicide squad or he
could be one of the villains that the
Suicide Squad is ordered to take down
not really sure how the movies going to
use them because the Joker is just going
to be one of many villains that is not
part of the Suicide Squad but bunch of
villains in this movie it's really a
movie full of villains but the Suicide
Squad characters are still protagonists
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
play the trailer again right about the
halfway point
keep your eyes peeled for his abilities
so you can kind of get an idea think
about him creating projections using the
tattoos when you watch his scenes again
so here we go
the escape from reality I want a simple
task force of the most dangerous people
on the planet they're bad guys worst of
the worst
was this a cheerleading tryouts
ah hi boys
good shot guy shoots people he's
crocodile he eats people burns people
you're possessed by witch she's just
crazy what was that I should kill
everyone in escape sorry the voices
I'm kidding that's not what they really
said this is the deal you're going
somewhere very bad do something don't
get killed so save the world I can't
wait to show you my toys let's do
something fun
me
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people for bad guys it's what we do
so I know that looks pretty trippy
especially that last shot with the cloud
like it does look like all the colors of
the emotional spectrum which which i
think is an easter egg for Green
Lantern's even though it's tattooed man
who technically is a Green Lantern
villain from the comics and Geoff Johns
did preview the Green Lantern's movie
that they're working on but that's still
a long ways out but they're basically
going to be doing almost every Green
Lantern you've ever heard of it's gonna
be amazing
so as you'd expect even though there's
not going to be a whole lot of Justice
League stuff it's mostly going to be
Suicide Squad stuff going on in this
movie they're laying a lot of ground
work along with Batman V Superman for
all the other Justice League related
films so don't be surprised at all if
you see Easter eggs for other DC
properties speaking of which
moving on to Scott Eastwood dick grace
and talk now this is this is just a
rumor people are like oh my god I hope
that he's going to be Nightwing agent 37
you know just just because he's working
as a secret agent in the comics so maybe
we'll see a version of that in the movie
universe but there's a lot of people
that think that in Batman V Superman
Dick Grayson is going to be the Robin
that the Joker has killed in the past so
all remains to be seen this could all
get flushed down the toilet Neyman
explained who agent 37 is because it's
one of the aliases of Dick Grayson when
he's undercover so quick primer in the
comics a while ago the crime syndicate
had fallen a new organization named
spiral was rising up Batman wanted to
investigate it so he asks Dick Grayson
to go undercover in Dick Grayson becomes
agent 37 to infiltrate this organization
eventually they sent Huntress in to team
up with him I know a lot of you guys are
Helena Bertinelli fans can't wait to see
hunters comeback on arrow she was one of
the more fun characters on that show
while this storyline is happening
everyone is led to believe that Dick
Grayson is dead like Batgirl
thinks that he's dead so he comes back
naturally he goes back in the comics and
everyone's pissed like how the hell
could you not tell us you're still alive
so right now in the comics like in the
back row comics they're kind of dealing
with that aftermath that obviously DC
has changed a whole bunch about their
comics I'm not expecting them to deal
with any of that in the movie if they do
Dick Grayson he could be a secret
undercover Dick Grayson but I don't
think
that's the case that it's kind of
wishful thinking but I do think that
Scott Eastwood definitely has the look
for it I just don't know if he has the
acting chops to hold screen time with
Ben Affleck there are plenty of other
Robins Batman has had many Robins but I
think what'll happen is is they'll just
touch on the dead Robin in Batman V
Superman and then they'll wait for the
Batman solo films to build that out like
I'm not expecting the Robin anytime soon
like an actual Robin next to Batman on
screen but you guys can let me know if
Dick Grayson is dead which version of
Robin do you want them to do on screen
in the movie universe I can see
everybody in the background just
screaming Nightwing like we don't want
other Robins just give us Nightwing but
in related news congratulations to the
most recent reverse flash ring giveaway
winner
Samuel Cho be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact info what I'm going to
do is I'm going to start a new round of
the giveaway whenever I post my next DC
video so leave all your requests there's
tons of other movie stuff that we could
talk about they dropped all kinds of
Justice League bombs this week so in
case you guys haven't seen it I totally
just posted a video where Ryan Reynolds
as Deadpool makes fun so much fun of
Wolverine you can click here to watch
that and you can click here to catch up
on legends of tomorrow flash and arrow
from this week thank you so much for
watching everybody let's have five I'll
see you guys tonight
you